اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في ساعه اخباريه مفصله
جديده نبداها بالعناوين
رغم تمديد الهدنه في السودان استمرار
الاشتباكات المتقطعه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريعه
نقابه اطباء السودان تعلن عن ارتفاع عدد
قتل المدنيين جراء الاشتباكات في البلاد
الى 411
نتاني صينيتان سوف تصلان بعد قليل الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي الاولى الان
العربيه تواصل عبر شبكه مراسليها متابعه
عمليات اجلاء الرعايه المستمره من السودان
دخان كثيف يملا سماء جزيره القرم جنوب
اوكرانيا بعد غاره بطائره مسيره
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا تغطيه العربيه مستمره للوضع
المتفجر في السودان منذ اسبوعين هو رغم
اعلان تمديد الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع لمده 72 ساعه بواسطه
سعودي امريكيه تواصلت المعارك بالطائرات
والدبابات حتى مسائل جمعه في الخرطوم وفي
اقليم دار غرب البلاد حيث ايقظ القتال
صراعا عمره عقدان المواجهات المشاهدين حتى
الان خلفت مقتل قرابه
574 قتيلا مع الكشف عن مقتل 74 شخصا في
مدينه الجنينه وحدها مطلع الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
اسبوع ثالث من الحرب في السودان لا صوت
يعلو على صوت الرصاص والمعارك تكوي ارضه
دون حسم نهائي لاي من الطرفين هدنه خامسه
قد توقف اطلاق النار نسبيا لكنها لن توقف
الحرب جغرافيا وساحه المواجهه الاساسيه
تحركت غربا من الخرطوم الى ولايه دارفور
حيث بدا الجيش السوداني بنقل جزء من
معركته في الخرطوم الى الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور والسبب قطع الطريق على
قوات الدعم السريع ومنع نقل معدات عسكريه
من الاقليم الى الخرطوم اما ابعادها
تستهدف قطع شرايين الجغرافيا وتفريغ جيوب
الاقليم من اي قوه مسلحه تشكل دعما اللحمه
لاندلاع الاشتباكات في الجنينه عده دلالات
فالبرهان يريد تخفيف الضغط العسكري في
العاصمه الخرطوم اضافه الى تشتيت انتباه
قوات الدعم السريع لكن ما يخشاه الجيش في
دارفور هو تاثيرات البيئه الاجتماعيه
والجغرافيه المتشابكه حيث تنشط قوات الدعم
السريع بحكم الامتدادات القبليه التي تصل
تشاد وربما تنحاز لصالح متي في لحظه معينه
من المعارك مراقبون حذروا من ان حياد
الحركات المسلحه في دارفور قد لا يستمر
طويلا اذا اشتد القتال في الاقليم ويمكن
ان تنحاز الى الجيش او الدعم السريع اما
الرعب الاكبر عند السودانيين يكمن في حصر
القتال في دارفور مجددا فاذا تفوق الجيش
على قوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم لن يكون
امام الاخيره سوى التحسن في دارفور فتح
جبهه دارفور مجددا يعيد الى الاذهان اجواء
الحرب الاهليه السابقه خصوصا ان من صنعوا
انتصارات الامس اصبحوا اعداء اليوم اياد
حمود العربيه
مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
لوصول سفينه اجلاء سعوديه قادمه من
السودان وعلى متنها
1982 شخصا من جنسيات عده في واحده من اكبر
عمليات الاجلاء منذ بدء الاحداث الاخيره
في السودان
ومباشره مشاهدينا في قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده معنا مراسل العربي سلطان
السلمي اهلا بك سلطان وكيف تسير عمليه
الاجلاء اذا في قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
نعم اهلا بك الان رست هذه السفينه المدنيه
التجاريه السعوديه وعلامتها 1982 شخص من
متعددي الجنسيات وصلوا من ميناء بورتسودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في رحله
استمرت 12 ساعه نتحدث ان هذه العمليه هي
الاكبر منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
كاعداد نتحدث على 1982 الشخص من اكثر من
45 جنسيه وايضا من الملفت ان من علامتنا
هذه السفينه قرابه المئه وخمسين الشخص من
العاملين بمنظمه الامم المتحده وهي الدفعه
الثانيه من اجلاء الرعايه التابعين لمنظمه
الامم المتحده بعد وصلت في يوم الربوع او
يوم الربوع الماضي قرابه 400 شخص من
العاملين بمنظمه الامم المتحده تفاصيل حول
عمليه اجلاء الرعايه التابعين او العاملين
بمنظمه الامم المتحده ينضم اليها الان
الاستاذ تامر حموده المستشار الامني
بمنظمه الامم المتحده بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
بدايه اهلا وسهلا على شاشه العربيه كيف
تمت عمليه الاجلاء وعدد الرعايه وكيف تمت
العمليه وكيف كانت تنسيق بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم دي تاني عمليه اخلاء لموظفي الامم
المتحده من دوله السودان الشقيقه احنا
عملنا العمليه الاخلال الاغنيه كانت يوم
الاربعاء الماضي حوالي 400 موظف
تحركوا من ميناء بورسودان الى ميناء جده
على متن باخره الحكومه السعوديه قدمت كل
الدعم اللازم لاخلاء عمليه اخلاء الموظفين
من اول ميناء بورسودان لغايه ما وصل مين
بناء جده ومن ميناء جده استقبلته من
الحكومه السعوديه مع
المتحده الموجوده في المملكه وتم
استضافتهم وتم تسهيل عمليه خروجهم من
ميناء جده الى مطار جده وتم نقلهم الى
مكان اخر النهارده عمليه الاخلاق ان شاء
الله اللي هتتم هيكون حوالي 155 موظف
ولا زال لدينا في السودان عدد من الموظفين
او المتحده الذي يقوده بتقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه للشعب السوداني فعمليه الاخلاق
ما تمتش كل موظفي الامم المتحده ان تمت
بعض الموظفين ويوجد بعض من الموظفين
موجودون لتقديم مساعدات الانسانيه في
السودان اسباب الاخلاء الرئيسيه من
السودان اليوم اسباب الاخلاق الرئيسيه
احنا بنخلي الموظفين في بعض الاحلام ما
تكون الاوضاع غير مستقره وفي الوضع الحالي
الوضع في السودان غير مستقر نسبيا فاحنا
بنخلي جزء من الموظفين وبنسيب جزء اخر
الجزء المتبقي ده بيكون بيدعم العمل
الانساني في السودان في الوقت الحالي
الاوضاع غير مستقره نسبيا فاحنا بنخلي
مؤقتا حتى تعود الى اوضاع الطبيعيه وبيتم
اعاده موظفين مره اخرى 150
شخص كم عدد الجنسياتهم وكذلك نتحدث انه
فيما يتعلق بعمليه النقل من ميناء بورت
سودان كما استمرت عمليه التنسيق مع
السفاره السعوديه لك او السلطات السعوديه
بشكل عام
عمليه الاخلاق تمت 12 ساعه هم من ميناء
بور سودان لغايه ميناء جده خدوا حوالي 12
ساعه في العباره وصلوا التنسيق تم ما بين
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وبين الامم
المتحده في السودان من خلال السفير
السعودي في السودان تمت تم تنسيق على اعلى
المستويات وده سهل الاجراءات في يوم
الاربعاء اللي فات وان شاء الله النهارده
الاجراءات تكون بسيطه وسهله بالنسبه
للموظفين او المتحده اليوم ابرز الاعمال
والمهام التي تقوم بها منظمه الامم
المتحده هنالك في السودان وفي الخرطوم
تحديدا في ظل الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السودان احنا يهمنا
في المقام الاول مساعده الاطفال المحتاجين
المساعدات والدور ده بتقوم به منظمه
اليونسيف بنحاول على قد ما نقدر ومنظمه
الصحه العالميه بتحاول تقدم الادويه
والعلاج على قد ما تقدر للمستشفيات
الموجوده العامله لان في بعض مستشفيات
اصبحت خارج نطاق الخدمه فمنظمه الامم
المتحده بتحاول تحصر عدد الاطفال اللي
محتاجين مساعدات من خلال منظمه اليونيسيف
منظمه الصحه العالميه وبتقدم لهم الدعم كل
الدعم الممكن تقدمونه في هذا التوقيت حتى
هذه اللحظه كم سجلتم اعداد او نسب او
احصائيات فيما يتعلق بالمساعدات والاشخاص
الاطفال تحديد المحتاجين للمساعده في
السودان الاعداد كبيره جدا لكن انا ما
عنديش الرقم محدد بصراحه لغايه دلوقتي لكن
اعداد كبيره جدا احتاجت مساعدات وبنقدم
لها مساعدات اللازمه على قد ما نقدر لان
في مناطق مش قادرين نوصل لها نتيجه
العمليات الجاريه هناك ولكن احنا مستمرين
في عملنا بالسودان وان شاء الله نقدر نوصل
لكل الناس ابرز الاحتياجات للمجتمع
السوداني هناك في ظل الاشتباك طبعا الغذاء
والادويه ده اهم حاجه محتاجينها الشعب في
التوقيت دوت لان معظم الامدادات توقفت فهم
محتاجين امتدادات من ناحيه الغذاء
والادويه كيف تشاهد
عمل السلطات السعوديه فيما يتعلق بعمليه
الاجلاء التي بدات منذ ايام الاجلاء
الرعايه من ميناء بورد سودان بمختلف
جنسيتهم الى قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
وكذلك الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وايضا الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بجد احنا من
ناحيه الامم المتحده احنا شايفين مجهود
جبار من الحكومه السعوديه لمساعده كل
اللاجئين
المحتاجين الاخلاء من من السودان وده تم
على يعني من اول مبادئه الازمه والحكومه
السعوديه
ما بتتاخرش في تقديم المساعدات لكل
الرعايه الاجانب والامم المتحده
والعرب
وساعدت في اخلاء عدد كبير جدا احنا شفنا
التنسيق ده وشوفنا المساعدات اللي الحكومه
السعوديه يوم الاربعاء اللي فات مع الامم
المتحده وسهلت اجراءات دخول الموظفين وان
شاء الله النهارده يتم على نفس المستوى
اللي حصل يوم الاربعاء اللي فات شكرا لك
كان معنا تامر حموده المستشار الامني
بمنظمه الامم المتحده بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
في الصوره المقابل نشاهد عدد من السفراء
وممثلي وممثلين دبلوماسيين تابعي لهؤلاء
الرعايه في انتظار فتح ابواب هذه السفينه
ونزولهاؤلاء الرعايه من علامات السفينه
امانه التجاريه تتابع الحكومه السعوديه
حتى يتم استقبالهم وتقديمك والتاكد من
حالاتهم الصحيه وتقديم الرعايه الصحيه
لهؤلاء الرعايه ممن يحتاجون وايضا سوف يتم
نقلهم عبر الاسطول المخصص من الحافلات الى
مقرات السكن بعد انهاء اجراءات الدخول الى
اراضي السعوديه ونؤكد ان الحكومه السعوديه
عملت على تقديم تسهيلات كبيره وحزمه من
البرامج والخدمات التي تعمل على تسهيل
وانزال هؤلاء الرعايه والتعامل بشكل
انساني وكبير هؤلاء الرعايه الذين قدموا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحرين يؤكد ان
قرابه الخمسه الاف شخص وصلوا منذ بدا
عمليات الاجراء الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه وهذه هي السفينه الثانيه السفينه
التجاريه الثانيه سفينه امانه هي من اثنا
عشر السفينه عشره سفن عسكريه بحريه
السعوديه واثنتين تجاريه وهي فقط امانه لا
سيما انه هذه السفليه التجاريه هي تستطيع
استيعاب اكبر عدد ممكن من الرعايه في وقت
السابق قامت بانزال
1687 اليوم تقوم بانزال
1982 من الرعايه باختلاف جنسيتهم كما نشر
ان هنالك ايضا رعايه من المواطنين
الايرانيين على متن هذه السفينه عددهم
قرابه الاربعه وستين بحسب المصادر سوف يتم
تقديم كافه الخدمات لهم ولكافه الرعايه
بمستوى واحد من خلال انهاء اجراءاتهم بشكل
سريع هنا في قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
وكذلك هل يتوقع
وصول دفعات اخرى ينتظر اجلائها في الساعات
المقبله خلال هذا اليوم في قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه
عملي
نعم عمليات الاجلاء مستمره منذ ايام لا
تتوقف منذ بدا عمليه الاجلاء ان كان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده وحتى الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي او حتى كذلك الى قاعده
الملك فيصل اوقات الملك عبد الله الجوي
متوقع خلال الساعات القادمه ان تصل احدى
السفن البحريه التابع للقوات البحريه
السعوديه وكذلك على متنها عدد من الرعايه
الاجانب الى جده شكرا لكم كنت معنا مباشره
من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي تحيه سلطان
مشاهدينا بعد 15 يوما من القتال عنيف ابدا
قائد قوات دعم السريع في مقابله مع قناه
بي بي سي ابدى استعداده لاجراء مفاوضات مع
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان بشرط وقف
اطلاق النار وقال حملت لهيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه انه طالب بالهدنه منذ اليوم
الاول للحرب وان قواته بدات بفتح ممرات
انسانيه داخل مناطق سيطرتها
وفي تصريح للعربيه قال يوسف عزه المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدانو قال ان قواته سيطرت على 90% من
ولايه الخرطوم وانها تستطيع الصمود في
المعارك لسنوات يوسف عزت لفت الى ان
المعركه فرضت على الدعم السريع وان وقف
اطلاقا وقف اطلاق النار مرتبط بتنفيذ
الجيش لذلك واكد عزه في لقائه مع العربي
حنا البرهان لا يدير المعركه ولا يستطيع
وقف النار على حد قوله
قوات الدعم السريع قادره على الصمود قادره
على الصمود واثبتت خلال اسبوعين من الحرب
المتواصله انها ليست مليشيا انها ليست
قوات متورده انها قوه منظمه تتبع خطط
عسكريه
مرتبه لدينا وساطه من
امريكا ومدعومه من السعوديه لدينا وساطه
من الايجاد لدينا وساطه من دول كثيره
صديقه ومنظمات ندرس كل هذه الخيارات ونحن
لسنا دعاه حرب ولا نريد استمرار الحرب ولا
نريد معاناه شعبنا
اي هنالك حل ياسس لسلام دائم
بالمقابل اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع بادخال اسلحه وجنود لمستشفى
الخرطوم وبتحويل المستشفى وبعض المدارس
للثقنات عسكريه وجاء في البيان ان
المتمردين مستمرون بقصف الخرطوم واندرمان
لاجبار السكان على الاخلاء لافتا الى ان
القصف العشوائي مستمر في محيط قياده بحري
والقياده العامه والدفاع الجوي واضاف
الجيش انه نفذ عمليه اجلاء عبر مطار وادي
سيدنا وبورسودان لرعايا بعض الدول
هذا وحثه القوه المدنيه المواقعه لاتفاق
الاطاري في السودان الطرفين على الالتزام
التام بوقف النار وشددت على ضروره التقيد
بتلك الهدنه التي وافق عليها قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم محمد
حمدان بصوره افضل من سابقاتها كما اشارت
الى انها تشد على ايدي قاده الجيش والدعم
السريع التي تعاطت بايجابيه مع المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه اما فيما يتعلق
بالاوضاع في الجنينه باقليم دارفور
فاعتبرت ان المواجهات القبليه الحاصله
نتيجه مباشره للقتال الذي استعر منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل الجاري بين القوتين
العسكريتين الكبيرتين في البلاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك سالم وهلا ما زال الهدوء الحذر
يخيم على شوارع الخرطوم
مرحبا احمد وبكل الساده المشاهدين عما زال
هناك هدوء حذر في العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها
الثلاث لكنه في منطقه شرق الخرطوم هذه
المنطقه التي نحن الان متواجدين فيها
الهدوء هنا يعني تشوبه كذلك حركه حركه
للمواطنين بالنسبه للمواطنين الذين يودون
الخروج من ولايه الخرطوم يضاف اليهم بعض
المواطنين الذين يريدون قضاء بعض
احتياجاتهم استغلالا لهذا الهدوء الذي
يعتبر مسيطر لوقت طويل منذ البارحه حتى
حتى اليوم عدا قليل من الاشتباكات في
مناطق متفرقه وبعيده من هذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه تشهد هدوء حذرا او نسبيا مع حركه
للمواطنين كذلك بحثا عن احتياجاتهم وكذلك
للوصول الى واحده من المحطات التي يغادرون
منها الى الولايات الشرقيه والولايات
الجنوبيه كذلك
طيب خروج هؤلاء المواطنين من مناطق
الخرطوم كما تفضلت هل يبدو ميسرا لان هناك
العديد من ارتكازات للطرفين خاص قوات
الدعم السريع بحسب بعض الانباء في مناطق
عده في ولايه السودان
صحيح احمد هذا مؤكد لكن في بعض الطرق الان
تكون سالكه خاصه في الصباح دائما نشهد ان
هذه الطرقات حتى وان كانت فيها القوات في
الصباح تكون هنالك حركه شبه طبيعيه تستمر
حتى الثانيه عشره والواحده ظهرا ثم بعد
ذلك تبدا يا موضوع تقل هذه الطرقات الى ان
تصل ذروتها في بمغيب الشمس سيصبح المرور
من هذه الطرقات الصعبه للغايه ربما
المواطنين الان يعني يجتهدون في قضاء
احتياجاتهم من الخروج لقضاء بعض ما
يحتاجونه من اكل وشرب وكذلك ما يحتاجونه
ايضا في بقيه مستلزماتهم الاخرى ايضا
لاحظنا ايضا عدد من المواطنين يخرجون بحثا
عن الوقود الذي فيه ندره حقيقيه في هذه
المنطقه وفي الاطراف كذلك موجود لكنه
بصعوبه هنا شبه منعدم هذا العنصر وهو
الوقود الذي يحتاجونه للحركه كذلك
المواصلات لم تعمل بشكل كامل هناك الان
قليل من العربات والسيارات التي يعني
يقتنيها المواطنين كمواصلات لكنها محدوده
جدا في طرق معينه جدا في محطات معينه كذلك
الوضع الامني ايضا في الخرطوم كيف يمكن
وصفه سالم بالحديث عن عمليات سلب ونهب
ربما نفذت في بعض المناطق في الايام
الماضيه
[موسيقى]
نعم احمد رصدت العديد من
الملفات المتعلقه بالسلب والنهب والشكاوى
والمواطنين المتكرره من هذا الامر في
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم هذا
الملف الامني حقيقه من الملفات المؤرقه
للمواطن السوداني في ظل هذه الظروف ظروف
صعبه حقيقه
بان يعني خاصه بعد مغيب الشمس ربما تنشط
هذه الحركات الاجراميه بالنهب والسلب
للمواطنين بالوصول الى منازلهم كذلك اخذ
ما يملكونه ثم بعد كل حادثه نجد
تبادل الطرفين للاتهامات ولكن في هنا
حقيقه مهمه ايضا احيانا تكون هذه العمليات
او غالبا تكون ليست من الطرفين اصلا
وهنالك ربما العمليات الاجراميه ربما هذه
المرحله وهذا الوقت مرتع خصب لمثل هذه
العمليات في ظل غياب الشرطه غياب دورها في
حمايه الممتلكات والمواطنين ربما هذا يدفع
ضعاف النفوس الى الذهاب لاخذ اموال الناس
والنهب والسلب كذلك فهذه من الملفات
المؤرقه تضاف الى فاتوره هذه الحرب خدمات
الكهرباء والمياه والانترنت ايضا هل عادت
ولو بشكل جزئي كيف هو وضعها حاليا في
الخرطوم
نعم احمد بالنسبه
للكهرباء هي ربما تكون الافضل في الثلاثه
الذين ذكرت الكهرباء هناك شعيله لوصولها
لكل المواطنين لكن ما زالت هناك مناطق
فيها تذبذب في التيار الكهربائي ومناطق
اخرى لا يوجد فيها تيار كهربائي اصلا منذ
اندلاع هذه الازمه لكن ربما هناك مجهودات
تقدم من الشركه القوميه للكهرباء بحثا عن
حلول
لمشكله الكهرباء ووضع حلول لها في ظرف
حقيقه امني صعب جدا في ظل انتشار للقوات
عدم التزام بالهدنه بشكل كامل كل هذه
الامور تجعل عمال الكهرباء يجدون صعوبه في
الوصول اما بالنسبه للاتصالات ففيها تذبذب
واضح ايضا حتى هذه اللحظه هناك اشكال واضح
في الاتصالات بكل اشكالها سواء الانترنت
او حتى الاتصالات اما بالنسبه للمياه فما
زالت مدينه بحره هي الاكثر ضررا الموضوع
المياه يضاف اليها بعض الاح الخرطوم وام
درمان بكل تاكيد لكن المدينه تباحيه تعاني
حقيقه من انقطاع مياه منذ اول يوم لاندلاع
هذه الازمه حتى هذه اللحظه 15 يوما حقيقه
كانت عصيبه او ما زالت عصيبه كذلك دفع
الكثير من المواطنين بالخروج من مدينه
بحري او كذلك الاعتماد على المياه الجوفيه
وهي مياه غير صالحه للشرب ويجد المواطن
صعوبه في نقلها في ظل عدم وجود محروقات
اصلا فيحتاج الى طرق بديله وبدائيه او
الحمل باليد وكل هذا تكلفه عاليه على
المواطن نعم اذا سنبقي علينا معك على اي
تفاصيل تطورات جديده في خرطوم شكرا لك
مراسله العربيه سالم الهاشمي تحيه سالم
مشاهدينا رجاح صحيفه امكانيه تقدم الجيش
السوداني على قوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم بحكم امكانياته العسكريه التي
تفوق تلك التي لدى الدعم السريع الا انها
ايضا لم تستبعد سيناريو اطاله امد النزاع
على يد قوات الدعم وتحويله الى حرب
استنزاف
على السلطه في السودان يخشى ان يتحول الى
حرب اكثر دمويه واطول امدا لكن طرفي
الصراع في العاصمه الخرطوم في وضعيتين
متباينتين فالقتال يجري بين مجموعتين
متفاوتتين في العدد والمعدات العسكريه
في تقرير لها رصدت قدرات الطرفين ومدى
امكانيه استمرارهما في القتال لفتره طويله
القوات المسلحه بقياده البرهان تملك اكثر
من 200 الف جندي جيش تقليدي يعرف شوارع
الخرطوم وتضاريسها مدرب على الدفاع عن تلك
المواقع بشكل جيد كما يدعمه سلاح الجو
بتشكيله من طائرات ماك 29 السوفيتيه
ومروحيات ومدرعات وصواريخ عدا عن ادارته
لمصنع عسكري يزوده بالذخيره والعربات
المدرعه في الجهه المقابله يتوقع خبراء
عسكريون القوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكريه
تقاتل بما يقرب من اربعين الف مسلح رغم ان
مصادر في الدعم السريع تقول ان عديدها
يقترب من 150 الفا وتعتمد هذه القوات على
تشكيله واسعه من مضادات الطائرات والعربات
المدرعه لكنها بطبيعه الحال لا تمتلك
سلاحا جويا غير ان هناك نقطه لصالح هذه
القوات بحسب
وهي الرواتب المجزيه مقرنه برواتب الجيش
السوداني وبحكم خلفيه تجنيدها كجماعات
مسلحه قبليه في دارفور وعلى حدود تشاد لا
درايه لقسم من عناصر الدعم السريع بتضاريس
العاصمه ولم يسبق ان توغلت فيها كما تتوغل
الان غير انها نجحت في ابتكار مسارات
جديده لتوفير الدعم بالذخيره لابقاء
عناصرها قادرين على خوض معارك استنزاف
طويله
لكن يبقى التحدي القائم امام الدعم السريع
هو كيفيه سيطره على العاصمه الخرطوم وهو
امر لم يحدث في التاريخ القريب من اي حركه
خارجه عن الجيش او من محاولات التمرد
المتعدده في السودان وعمر العربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ناشد امين عام اوه المتحده في مقابله خاصه
مع العربيه ناشد السودانيين للعوده الى
الحوار واكد ان الامم المتحده ستعمل بكل
جهدها للوصول لحل لازمه السودان انه من
دواعي سرور
واسمح لي قبل ان نبدا
ابعث برساله الى الشعب السوداني
لكل هؤلاء السودانيين الذين يستمعون لي
اود ان اعبر عن تضامن العميق وتضامن الامم
المتحده العميق عندما كنت المفاوض الاعلى
للاجئين زرتوا السودان عده مرات وكنت
دائما
مندهشا بحسن الضيافه والكرم في شعب
السودان كنا نرى اللاجئين من من اريتيريا
واحيانا يشاطرنهم توفر لديهم من موارد من
خلال نظام يعتمد على الاخويه نظام رائع
ولرؤيه هذا الشعب الشجاع هذا الشعب السخي
يعاني بهذا القدر كما نراه اليوم هذا امر
يبعث على الصدمه ويزعجني للغايه
وهناك
جمله من الامور التي يجب ان نقدم
نقدمها الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن السودان
وسوف تفعل كل ما بوسع من اجل تامين الظروف
الامنيه من اجل تقديم الدعم الانساني
للشعب السوداني وكذلك ايضا
المفوضيه العليا
والتي عملت بها لمده عقده من الزمن هي
فاعله في
هناك وسوف تضمن بان اللاجئين الذين يعبرون
سوف يتم استقبالهم بطريقه مكرمه وهذا صراع
اود منه ان ينتهي وسوف نفعل كل ما بوسنا
من اجل التوصل للوقف دائما لاطلاق النار
والسودان ليعود للحوار
والتوصل الى حاله من الاستقرار وتمهيد
الطريق لانتقال الديمقراطي فشعب السوداني
كان يحارب من اجل هذا المرج
هذه هي الهدنه الثالثه خلال الساعات
الاثنتين والسبعين الاخيره انا والاتحاد
الافريقي وايجاد وجامعه الدول العربيه كنا
نهيب بوقف اطلاق النار ورغم انخفاض منسوب
القتال لكن الهدنه لم تصمد وتم استئناف
القتال اكثر من 1200 من موظفي الامم
المتحده تم نقلهم عبر بورد سودان اود ان
اشكر الاطراف تحدثت معهم لكن للاسف يستمر
القتال يجب ان نتحد كاسره دوليه ونعمل مع
الاتحاد الافريقي وايجاد ورئيس كينيا
ورئيس جنوب السودان ورئيس جيبوتي يجب فعل
كل شيء من اجل خلق ظروف مواتيه والتحدث مع
البرهان وحميتي واطراف اخرى انها مساله
شعب يطمح الى قياده مدنيه سياسيه
ان الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن السودان
وستفعل كل ما بوصحيحها لتوفير ظروف
الامنيه من اجل تقديم الدعم الانساني
للسودانيين
الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن السودان وستفعل
كل ما بوسعها لتوفير الظروف الامنيه من
اجل تقديم الدعم الانساني للشعب السوداني
هذا صراع يجب ان ينتهي وسنفعل كل ما
بوسعنا للتوصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
ليعود هذا البلد الى الحوار والاستقرار
وتمهيد الطريق الانتقال الديمقراطي الشعب
السوداني كان يحارب من اجل هذا الامر
وفي مقابله اخرى مع العربيه اكدت مندوبه
بريطانيا في الامم المتحده ان بلادها تهدف
للحصول على دعم مجلس الامن لمقترحات
الاتحاد الافريقي وايجاد فيما يخص الوضع
الحالي في السودان
ما نود فعله هو الحصول على الدعم الكامل
من مجلس الامن لمقترحات ايجاد والاتحاد
الافريقي للتقدم نحو وقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم
العوده للعمليه السياسيه
ونحن كبريطانيا خصصنا 250 مليون جنيه
استرليني لنحو 50 مليون شخص بحاجه لمساعده
انسانيه فوريه الامم المتحده ايضا بقيت في
السودان لتقديم المساعدات اما الخطوه
التاليه هي العوده للعمليه السياسيه
ومنظم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي
خالد الاعسر اهلا بك سيد خالد معنا في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه دعونا نبدا من حديث
البيبيسي الذي عبر فيه عن استعداده للجلوس
في طاوله المفاوضات مع البرهان هل يمثل او
تمثل هذه التصريحات تحول في الاستراتيجيه
او في رغبه الدعم السري في التعاطي مع هذه
الازمه بشكل مختلف اذا مقيس ذلك بتصريحاته
السابقه التي حملت الكثير من
كانت هناك نبره حاده واضحه في تصريحات
تجاه البرهان وبعض الاسات ايضا لقائد
الجيش
انا في تقديري ون وحسن الافكار وندفع بها
باتجاه انها تتم وتكتمل حتى يعني يجني
ثمار الشعب السوداني وهذه كانت الخطوات
التي صبغت عمليه اطلاق الطلقه الاولى
بمناسبه كانت هناك مسائل كي يكون محمد
حمدان شخصيا رجل وطني سوداني يستجيب
لنداءات التي كانت تدور خلف الكواليس لجمع
مع الفريق البرهان في جلسه وسافات وطنيه
تنتهي بالازمه قبل ان تندلع الطرصاصه
الاولى ولكن لا باس الان حدث ما حدث والان
يجب ان يتدارك الناس مثل هذه العثرات التي
تمت عسى والعل ان تكون في صفحه جديده في
المستقبل ولكن هذا المستقبل لن يكون كما
كان عليه الحال قبل 15
ابريل الجاري باعتبار ان المعطيات التي
تمت على صعيد دمج القوات ويعني فرض سلطه
المؤسسه العسكريه والدماء الكبيره التي
راحت كضحايا وشهداء لهذه العمليه والتدمير
المريع للبناء التحتيه هذا يفرض التزامات
جديده ونوع من القبول بشروط جديده
ومفاوضات على شكل جديد ليس كما كان عليه
الحال في يوم 15 ابريل كان التنبؤ بماهيه
هذه الشروط الجديده والوضع الجديده
والواقعه جدا عليه السودان ما هي النقطه
الوسطى التي يمكن ان يتوصل اليها طرفان
نزاع في اي مفاوضات مستقبليه
اول شرط لن يقبل عنه اي سوداني ان يمر
مرور الكرام وان تدمجات الدعم السريع كشرط
اولي بند اول لا تراجعوا عنه مهما كلف
الامر لانه الذي كان يخشاه الناس في صراع
الدموي الذي يمكن ان ينشف في حال وجود
معارك عسكريه وهذا دفع البعض للتماهي مع
افكار تمديد فكره الدمج لاجيال زمنيه هذا
الامر
انتهى كل الشعب السوداني دفع ثمنا بايضا
ويجب ان ينتهي امر الدمج وقد انتهى بالفعل
بالمناسبه في عدد من الولايات ربما 17
ولايه وحتى في الخرطوم هذه قضيه تجاوزها
الزمن محمد حمدان دوبلو قائد الدعم السريع
مواطني سوداني يستحق ان يكون في منظومه
وادعى السوداني الجديد ولكن بموجب مال
تمليه شروط الدوله وليس شروط الافراد
والمصالح الخارجيه
والتحالفات وهذا الدمار الذي
لم يقبل الشعب السوداني اي معادله جديده
تتيح لغوه عسكريه خارج مظله المؤسسه
العسكريه الاولى طيب يعني يبدو انك متفائل
يعني بامكانيه اصلاح تم تدميره من علاقات
بين رجلين لكن البرهان اكد مرارا ان لا
خلافات لديه مع دعم السريعي وككل وانما مع
ال دلو فقط يعني حتى قاده الدعم السيريكان
يصارحون خلافتهم مع البرهان وليس مع
المؤسسه العسكريه ككل الا يش ذلك بان
الازمه هي بعيده عن نطاقها القومي فعلا
وانها في الاساس معركه تصفيه حسابات شخصيه
بين رجلين
ليس صحيحا تفضلت في قناتكم المحترم بالامس
على نشر حوار مع الامين العام المتحده وقد
ذكر ذلك بصريح العباره ان الحرب ليست بين
جنرين وانما هناك دور لاطراف كثيره خارجيه
وداخليه هذه الحرب ليست هذه الحرب اخطر
حرب على السودان في تقييم الشخصي وبحكم
معرفه للتاريخ السودان القديم والحديث
هذا في تاريخ الحياه السياسيه
والمستقبليه للسودان السودان سيرهض بقوه
بعد هذه الحرب سيتلف وتوحد وجدان الوطني
بصوره اكبر مما كان عليه الحال تكشفت كل
خيوط المؤامرات الخارجيه الشعب السوداني
من اصغر طفل اكبر كهل يعلمون الان ان
بلادهم مستهدفه لاهداف محدده من جهات
محدده وستحاسب وخير دليل على ذلك بين
القوات المسلحه اليوم ذكرت لكم هنا في هذه
القناه منذ ايام ان ما بعد المعركه ستكون
هناك تصفيه حسابات مع مؤسسات اعلاميه ومع
دول عشان نكون صريحين هناك يعني برنامج
كبير رتب لاجهاض هويه الدوله ولضرب
السودان في في وعده
لتفكيك السودان وللاستثار بمكاسب الشعب
السوداني هذه المعلومات لم تعد لدى النخبه
ولا الصفوه توجد عند اي مواطن سوداني مهما
كانت درجه
او تعليمه شكرا لذلك من لندن كنت معنا
الكاتب اعتذر منك استاذ خالد نعم سامحني
لم يبقى لذيذ من الوقت من لندن كنت مع
الكاتب الصحفي خالد الاعسر مشاهدينا نتابع
معكم هذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ونرى فيها اعمده الدخان
جراء اشتباكات دارت ربما في وقت سابق بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
ونحن مشاهدينا في اليوم الخامس عشر لهذه
الاشتباكات رغم اعلاني تمديد الهدنه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لمده
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه بواسطه سعوديه امريكيه
ينضم الى الان مشاهدينا من الخطوبه مكاتب
الصحفي عمرو شعبان اهلا بك سيد عمرو وبحسب
ما يتوفر لك المعلومات حاليا هل تدور
اشتباكات في مكان ما في الخطوبه لان هناك
صور الان مباشره تابعه على شاشه العربيه
لاعمده الدخان متصاعده من ما يبدو انه وسط
الخرطوم
مرحبا بك نعم بالتاكيد جرس العديد من
الاشتراكات خلال هذا اليوم كما هي الاعاده
يعني في الرابعه والسعه عشر دقيقه بالضبط
كان هناك فرصه على مستوى الخرطوم يمتد في
ذات الخارطه
المناطقيه المعتاده القصر الجمهوريه حدود
القياده العامه
قوات الدعم السريع ويسمع صوت الطيران
والقسط ومن ثم المضادات الارضيه وبالتالي
تتوقف قليلا ومن ثم تعاود مره اخرى وبين
الصينا نسمع اصوات طائرات بدون اي قصه
ربما استطلاع اللي يكتشف مواقع قوات الدعم
السريع يقوم بها يقوم بها الجيش السوداني
عموما الان نحن في حاله ما يقارب الساعه
او الساعه الا لا نسمع اي صوت
او قصه
تلغين معتاده خلال المصطفى النهار ومن ثم
تعاود مره اخرى بشراسه وبشكلها اكبر كما
هي العاب طيب استاذ عمرو يعني الى ما يعود
تكرار خرق هذه الهدن وانهيار بعضها تماما
يعني هل يتحمل الطرفان معا مسؤوليه هذه
الخروقات ان احدهما ربما يفتقد الجديه
والاراده اللازمه التزام بهذه الهدن
صدقني موضوع الهدن حينما يتم الاعلان من
قبل الطرفين به هو محاوله منهما منهما
باعتبارهم موضوعيا الصراع الذاتي ومرتبط
بشخصيته جنراليه بشخصيتين الذين قالها
بشكل واضح ام الحرب وهو حرب وجوديه وكلهم
الاخر بالتالي حينما تطرح دول بثقل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامريكيه
محاوله التوسط والتهدئه او الهدن يتم
اجابتها بالموافقه ولكن في ذات الوقت يضمر
الطرفين
القفز من هذه اول نقطه من هذه الهدنه
لصالحهم الشخصي
الطرفين حينما يلتزمان بالهدنه بشكل واضح
ان هذا الامر للازال اجانب
وتشغيل عمليات الاجزاء لصالح
القوى الرعايه الدولي الاخرى لكن لا احد
منهم يهتم للمواطن السوداني حتى يكون امرا
الهدنه جديا يرتبط الاوض
اع على جثثهم او تقديم العزاء او
الحصول على التعيينات والمواد الضروريه
واللازمه او حتى لصيانه بعض الخدمات التي
يحتاجها للمواطنين سواء كانت الكهرباء او
مواسير المياه
هذا الامر لا يحصل فيه جناره لين ولا
قوتين التي تتصارعون على الارض حاليا طيب
يعني كون هذا الصراع هو صراع شخصي كما
وصفته بين الجنرلين يعني هل هذا يفسر وقوف
المجتمع الدولي على الحياه تماما في هذه
الازمه
ووقفي على مسافه واحده دعنا نقول من
الطرفين رغم الشرعيه التي يتمتع بها الجيش
يعني حتى الان لم نرى او لم نسمع عن دوله
اعلنت مساندتها التامه للقوات المسلحه رغم
كونها القوه الشرعيه الوحيده في هذا
الصراع
دعني اقول لك امرا يجب استصحابه محاوله
تلقى المجتمع الدولي وسواب في شقيه
امريكا على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى
مستوى المنظمه العموميه الوضع في السودان
معقد ومركب للحد الذي وصل به الاستياح
المجتمع الدولي والاقليمي حق
الحاجه لعضم صياغه المشهد وربما وجدت كل
هذه الاطراف في الحرب الحاليه مساحه
لاعاده تركيب خطوه تركيب المشهد لصالح
ترتيبه بشكل يدبر يستطيع من خلاله المجتمع
دول اقليم التعامل مع السودان مع صياغاته
ثانيا الحديث عن مشروعيه القوات الشعب
المسلحه والجيش هذا عمره مفروغ منه الجيش
مؤسسه بمواصفات الدوله السودانيه بالتاكيد
السوداني لا يريد لهذا الجيش ولكن مع
اصحاب هذه الفرضيه ان قائد الجيش الحالي
الذي يشيل هذه
هو ذاته من اصبر على الدعم السريع مشروعيه
حينما قال انه من رحيم الجيش وانهم الجيش
وهم يحملون المواطنون حينما يكون الاخرون
نعيمون بالتالي ليس بمجرد نعلم قائد الجيش
لهذه القوه ليست قوه تابعه للجيش سيحترف
المجتمع الدولي بان هذه القوه الامر الان
في نظره مجتمع الدوله ان الجيش صار مع احد
افرعوا المتمرده
في الطرفين القائدين اولين على الارض حتى
يدفع الثمن لكن محاوله جره رفض دوليه
واقليميه اخرى يفتح
الباب صراحه موقفا موان لاحد الاطراف او
محاوله ادخال يدها في هذا الملف بالتاكيد
روسيا في هذا الملف
فرنسا القادسه قلها فه
ذا الامر في هذا الامر الان نستمع بشكل
واضح لصوت جنوب السودان من خلال الايجاد
نستمع صوت واضح تحت الامريكيه والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه في ملف الهدن يخفض الصوت
المصري يخفض الصوت الاماراتي يخفت العديد
من الاصوات التي
اعتذر منك دعم الوقت بشكل كبير من الخرطوم
كنت اذا الكاتب الصحفي عمرو شعبان شكرا
استاذ عمرو
مشاهدينا الجيش السوداني حاول خلال
السنوات الماضيه عزيزه وجوده العسكري على
حدود الدول الجهراء للسودان ضمن
استراتيجيه هدفها الحفاظ على الامن وتجاوز
الاختلالات الامنيه التي يمكن ان تؤثر على
الطرق الحيويه في شرق القارات الافريقيه
حرب البرق الخاطفه تدخل اسبوعها الثالثه
في السودان والتداعيات يمكن ان تصل لدول
الجوار التي تشترك معه في حدود بريه
فالجيش السوداني طيله السنوات الماضيه
حاول حمايه حدوده والحفاظ عليها ضمن
استراتيجيه عسكريه تتماشى مع جغرافيا
المواقع بدايه من الشمال تحديدا الحدود
المصريه حيث توجد مناطق عسكريه تابعه
للجيش السوداني جنوبي مثلث حلايب في ولايه
البحر الاحمر ايضا تنتشر القوات السودانيه
في المثلث السوداني الليبي حيث توجد قاعده
مركزيه كبيره للجيش السوداني في الدوله
المضطربه امنيا كما ان تشاد التي تشترك
بحدود تزيد عن الفين كيلو متر مع السودان
تنتشر في حدودها قوات سودانيه مشتركه
هدفها تامين الحدود من المرتزقه
وفي افريقيا الوسطى التي تمزقها الحرب
يوجد الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط تفتيش
عسكريه فقط اما على الحدود السودانيه التي
يمكن ان تتحول لقاعده لتدفق السلاح ينتشر
الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط تفتيش كبرى في
كسلا والحدود المتاخمه مع اريتريا ضمن
حاميات عسكريه وفي اثيوبيا التي تخوض مع
السودان نزاعا حدوديا غير محسوم ينتشر
الجيش السوداني في منطقه الفشقه التي تقع
في ولايه القضارف وايضا في منطقه القلابات
وولايه النيل الازرق وفي جنوب السودان
هناك العديد من المناطق العسكريه ينتشر
فيها الجيش شمالي ابياي وجنوبي كردفان
وولايه النيل الابيض
فالجيش السوداني حاول خلال السنوات
الماضيه اتباع استراتيجيه تحكمها ضوابط
عسكريه لتعزيز وجوده على الحدود
مع دخول المواجهه يومها الخامس عشر تواصل
عواصم الدول اجلال رعاياها و الهاربين من
القتال الدائر في السودان منذ اسبوعين
السعوديه تمثل قطع عبور رئيسيه لعدد من
هذه الدول عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي وقاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه
في هذا السياق مشاهدينا قال العقيد مسفر
الجريني المتحدث الرسمي لحرس الحدود
السعودي في تصريحات للعربيه ان حرس الحدود
في ميناء جده سخر جميع الامكانيات البشريه
والماديه والتقنيه لاستقبال ضيوف عمليه
الاجلاء من السودان حيث وصلت سفينه
صينيتان تحملان رعايه من الصين وباكستان
مباشره حرس الحدود مهام من ضمن الاعمال
والمهام المنوطه بوزاره الداخليه
والقطاعاتها
المشاركه في تقديم المساعده في عمليات
الاجلاء
للمواطنين او الرعايه الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه من السودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي والتي سنحت لهم حكومه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
عمليات الاجلاء الى حتى وصولهم الى جده
ومن ثم المغادره الى بلادهم بكل امن
وسلامه يقوم حرص حدود بالعديد من المهام
من ضمنها حفظ الامن والسلامه داخل الميناء
وكذلك
المنطقه المحيطه به كما يقوم حرس حدود
بتنظيم الحافلات والمركبات داخل الميناء
لتحقيق الامن والسلامه للجميع طبعا سخر
حرس الحدود جميع الامكانيات الماديه
والبشريه والتقنيه لخدمه هؤلاء القادمين
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انسانيا اكد برنامج غذاء العالمي في بيان
ان الوضع في السودان اصبح كارثيا هو ان
اسعار المواد الغذائيه في السودان ارتفعت
بشكل صاروخي واكد برنامج الغذاء العالمي
التزام باستئناف عمليته في السودان داعيا
الى ضروره التوقف القتال ولفت برنامج
الغذاء العالمي الى انه يجري تقييما للوضع
الامني في السودان لتحديد المواقع الهادئه
لتقديم المساعدات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات